Echos de clapotis
Musique intrigante
...
Les clapotis s'intensifient.
Clapotis étouffés
...
En anglais
Brouhaha
...
Applaudissements et acclamations
Applaudissements
Musique intrigante
...
Crépitements
*Propos en anglais à la télévision
*...
Musique éthérée
...
La musique s'intensifie.
Sa voix se répète en écho.
...
La voix de la fillette
se répète au loin.
...
Musique intrigante
*Propos en anglais à la télévision
*...
Discussions animées et rires
...
Musique planante
Grognements d'effort
...
Propos en anglais
-Nous sommes ici un institut
de recherche en biologie,
en sciences de la vie,
et notamment la recherche
du vieillissement,
des causes du vieillissement,
de la chimie du vieillissement,
et des conséquences,
qui impliquent les maladies
et, finalement, la mort.
Où on en est,
après une dizaine d'années
de recherche assez intensive ?
On est toujours dans ce manque
de connaissances
sur la racine de la cause
du vieillissement,
par laquelle on peut comprendre
toutes les nombreuses manifestations
du vieillissement.
Toutes ces maladies incurables
qui nous tuent,
il y en a des centaines,
environ 200,
qui dépendent toutes
de l'horloge biologique,
horloge du cancer
et horloge de la longévité,
en directe relation,
et l'hypothèse
la plus simple,
c'est qu'il y a une cause commune.
Mon approche est :
"Allons chercher la cause commune."
Si on la trouve,
ça serait extrêmement important,
car s'il y en a une commune
à toutes les maladies malignes,
dégénératives, etc.,
mais il suffit de considérer
cette cause
comme un biomarqueur,
de la supprimer,
ou au moins sa première conséquence,
et à ce moment-là,
il serait plus simple
de prévenir toutes les maladies
d'un coup
qu'une seule isolée.
On en a déjà parlé, l'exemple,
dans la population humaine,
ce sont les centenaires,
qui, typiquement,
ne souffrent d'aucune
de ces centaines de maladies.
Et donc, les centenaires,
c'est la source
de mon optimisme,
qu'on pourra vivre
jusqu'à 120 ans,
presque tout le monde.
Mais ça veut pas dire
que cette limite est immuable.
Il faut modifier génétiquement
l'homme
pour qu'il vive au-delà de 120 ans.
Alors on cherche,
pour les humains,
parce que c'est pas évident
de modifier génétiquement
la lignée germinale humaine,
c'est même interdit pour le moment,
il faut changer le potentiel,
probablement le métabolisme,
et ça, je n'anticipe pas.
Certainement,
je vivrai pas le temps
de voir ces recherches
sur la modification génétique
humaine.
Donc, nous, soyons modestes,
et voyons comment
réduire au maximum,
mieux éliminer
les sources principales
de la souffrance humaine.
La majorité des gens
n'ont pas tellement
de problèmes avec le fait
qu'ils ne sont pas éternels,
qu'ils vont mourir :
ils savent qu'ils vont mourir,
mais ils ont peur
de la façon dont ils vont mourir.
Est-ce que ce sera
à cause du cancer,
ou Alzheimer, la démence...
Ils ont peur de ça.
Y a 4 personnes sur 10 000
qui n'ont pas ce problème,
ce sont les centenaires.
Et voilà, notre projet, "modeste",
c'est d'éliminer la source
des souffrances
à cause des maladies
et que les gens vivent,
jusqu'au bout,
sans avoir peur de la souffrance
liée à la cause de la mort.
Propos en anglais
Musique mystérieuse
...
Reflux
Le vent souffle.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Musique douce
...